haiti's president jevenelle muis has
been assassinated at his private
residence
the country's interim prime minister
says the killing happened when a group
of unidentified men
attacked the home in porter france the
53 year old was elected in 2016
and had been ruling haiti by decree for
the last two years
his wife was injured in the attack and
has been hospitalized
haiti has seen an increase in
politically motivated violence over
recent months
the country's also suffering a
humanitarian crisis because of shortages
of
food let's get
more from avid law marine corps who's
editor-in-chief
of able post an online news agency in
port-au-prince
and welcome to dw so what more
is known about how the president met his
end
okay uh we don't know more than what is
being reported in the media
um according to the prime minister he
gave an interview
at a radio station and he also sent out
a press release
uh this morning at 1 00 am
a commando with people in it who spoke
french and who spoke english and spanish
these people attacked the residence of
the president
and uh during this attack um the
president was killed
his wife is uh was injured and she
is uh in a critical condition at a
hospital right now
right and and did this attack come out
of nowhere
haiti has been suffering um economically
and uh
going through a period of of uh
political instability as well
okay so i'm repeating uh a human rights
organization
uh lawyer we are in a state of confusion
right now in haiti
uh the country is mainly controlled by
group
of armed gangs and some of these gangs
were
allegedly having ties to the government
um the government was uh
is i mean is contested by a large part
of the opposition
um and they were trying to organize
elections um and change the constitution
which is illegal uh as well so who is in
charge of the country
at the moment with the uh with the
president dead
that's a good question uh because uh we
have constitutional uh path
for these type of things but um
most institutions in haiti are not
working properly um
you don't have a parliament uh that is
working properly the chamber of deputies
does not exist and you only have one
trade of the senators
uh we don't have a judicial system which
is working
um and the prime minister that is who
sent out
this press release saying the government
is taking
uh the situation under control and
trying to like bring
a peace uh to to to people's minds uh
it's a resigning government because just
before the president was
killed he he nominated a new
prime minister uh of course the transfer
of power from this
previous prime minister to this to the
new wasn't uh
effective we are hearing uh from lawyers
and from
people that you know folks should get
together
and and try to find a new way because
there is no legal
pathways to um to
uh to to escape the situation that we're
living right now there is no
legality nothing in the books wow okay
thank you so much for for joining us and
uh outlawing
outlining that uh to us uh vidlo meranko
from aiebo post in porter prize